bonsoir c'est le gouvernement qui s'est
donc prononcé hier sur la prolongation
du confinement jusqu'au 3 mai date
possible d'un déconfinement avant de
revenir sur les mesures qu'il entend
prendre pour le mois du ramadan quelles
sont ces mesures effectivement stéphane
est un rendez vous qui était très
attendue par le peuple tunisien que le
chef du gouvernement a été passé à la
télé donc interviewés par deux
journalistes de la chaîne el nacional il
est revenu sur la situation en tunisie
sur les décès dont 38 comme vous l'avez
dit avec 879 cas enregistrés les il a
également noté que 43 patients étaient
est guéri après avoir été admis auprès
des hôpitaux tunisiens présentant bien
sûr tous les symptômes du co lead 19 il
est revenu sur ce confinement qui
prenait fin hier il a annoncé qui sera
prolongé jusqu'au 3 mai prochain à
partir du 4 mai il va y avoir un
déconfinement partiel qui sera organisée
donc ce sera par secteur par région et
surtout par âge donc le gouvernement
reviendra bien sûr sur les modalités du
déconfinement qui sont prévus pour le 4
mai prochain il a noté également que les
personnes âgées puis les personnes
vulnérables et toute personne malade
devait continuer de respecter ce
confinement pour pouvoir maîtriser la
situation gouvernement avait peut-être
déclaré que la situation était maîtrisée
par rapport aux voisins du maghreb
l'algérie et le maroc qui enregistre
beaucoup plus de décès au co plus de
personnes contaminées
il est revenu également sur la période
du ramadan qui doit s'ouvrir dans un peu
moins d'une semaine donc c'est une très
grosse problématique dans tous les pays
musulmans une problématique également en
france comment vont s'organiser les
musulmans pour pouvoir passer ce mois du
ramadan le gouvernement a dit que rien
n'avait changé si ce n'est que l'heure
du couvre-feu qui est à 18 heures à
tunis va passer à 20 heures pour pouvoir
permettre aux tunisiens de de pouvoir
célébrer ce mois saint et les mosquées
resteront fermées donc pas de prières
collectives d'aprilia propre au mois de
ramadan qui doit se dérouler après la
rupture du jeûne aura là pas lieu il
appelle tous les tunisiens à respecter
ces normes de sécurité et pour pouvoir
bien sûr maîtriser et puis lutter contre
soko vie des 19 et la main également
annoncé qu'une aide financière
supplémentaire sera attribué aux
familles les plus démunies pour pouvoir
s'en sortir durant ce mois de ramadhan
et on l'a appris il ya quelques heures
mais c'est mains des tunisiens bloqués
en libye temps de rejoindre la tunisie
de force l'armée étaient déployés à la
frontière entre la tunisie et la libye
effectivement c'est triste un communiqué
du ministère de l'intérieur et puis
beaucoup d' images qui circulent sur
facebook énormément tunisiens sont
bloqués en libye depuis la crise du
coronavirus ils demandent à rejoindre la
tunisie
mais depuis le début du confinement
comme beaucoup de pays dans le monde la
tunisie a fermé ses frontières la libye
est également fermé ses frontières
puisqu'ils étaient problématiques pour
ces tunisiens de ces centaines de
tunisiens qui essayaient de rejoindre la
tunisie
j'ai appris de source sûre que c'est des
milices qui sont stationnés dans les
frontières entre la libye la tunisie
dans certains points c'est mieux cela
aurait ouvert les portes de la libye
pourrait d'ailleurs permettre d'accéder
à la tunisie donc ça a été un gros
problème pour l'armée pour pouvoir gérer
pour les douaniers pardon pour pouvoir
gérer cet afflux massif de tunisiens
donc l'armée a été appelée en renfort
beaucoup de policiers aussi appelé en
renfort on a compté à peu près plus de
658 selon le ministère de l'intérieur
mais d'après les sources que j'ai des
personnes qui sont sur place il serait
beaucoup beaucoup plus nombreux à
vouloir regagner la tunisie le
gouvernement craint que parmi ces
personnes qui veulent regagner la
tunisie il n'y ait des terroristes ou ou
des personnes qui sont dans cette
intention par dans un maxi elle pour
entrer en tunisie
vous savez qu'elle s'attelle aux
frontières est très très sensible et
c'est un casse tête pour le gouvernement
tunisien ont beaucoup de contrôles ont
été faits pour prouver qu'ils sont
tunisiens qu'ils ont des papiers et puis
un passeport aux tunisiens pour pour
être identifiée avant de rentrer dans le
pays et ces personnes là ont été
transportés dans le sud dans la région
de tozeur dans un hôtel pour être
confinés durant 14 jours l'opération est
toujours en cours donc l'armée essaie
tant bien que mal de contrôler cet
afflux massif de tunisiens étudiants qui
étaient restés bloqués qui demandait
depuis depuis très longtemps déjà au
gouvernement de pouvoir être rapatriés
en tunisie
merci beaucoup bassem chez billets en
direct de tunisie donc